all right sandy
yes sandy uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally well
i'm from l.a and uh you grew up with uh
your family you're both parents no
not both parents my father was deceased
and my mom was a single parent
and how was your childhood my childhood
was up and now
you know stayed in and out of homes jail
group homes things like that
so my mom was how did mom lose you
what type of mama had no how did your
mom lose you to the group well
drugs of course you know that's how
oh it's a common story right common
story of black homes
priority homes especially that time
right yeah
so what kind of could be in high school
um i could pleaded high school i
graduated in 2006
so i did i started off being doing
nursing
and um fell
in the life of prostituting
unknowingly at what age age
19. and how did you start with a pimp or
on your own
i started on my own doing car girl
situation and i met a friend and she
said this guy wanted to meet us
and before i knew i was kidnapped
by a so-called friend and her pet
so i ended up being
his [ __ ] and
i had to go out and make his money every
day
so instead of keeping the money yourself
you're now giving it to him
every dime wow every single dime
it was horrible so you kind of felt
pressured or oh i was
i was definitely pressured because first
of all i was kidnapped i was ticking
away f
took them away from my family um
went out for one night a night of fun
with with my friend
have some drinks smoke some pot and next
thing i know i never returned home
how long did that go on i went on about
like five years
all the way until i was probably 24.
tell me a little bit about that
arrangement um
the arrangement was that i needed to
make this money for him and if i didn't
that you know
i'll be unfound unrecognized basically
because now he owns me
so late nights
all the way to maybe six in the morning
we i can come in the house a lesson i
made probably three thousand dollars
if not i guess they call it nowadays
gorilla pimpin
so his name was mr p
mr p was the big bad pimp of mine
so how would you describe mr pete he was
he was a tall
handsome gentleman he seemed very nice
and
very caring but to close doors he was
something the world can even describe
who's a monster you know he would force
us to do drugs such as you know
crystal meth um something to relax
us so we wouldn't feel the things that
we were doing we needed to step out of
our person
and become a different person so every
day i'll dress up to be someone else so
i wouldn't feel
my feelings so i'll go out put on
different
acts and roles you know mainly
i would get more of
i want to say guys that would like to be
beat and
whooped and spanked so
and that's how i will make my money
so how did you break free from that well
i met i want to say a guy that was my
guardian angel
and kind of was in the same line of
business i was going to be a porn star
and somehow i got with this
this russian guy he wanted me to be a
part of his porn industry
and i went down for my testing and all
that
and i didn't pass the test
which was it was false i went to my
doctor
later on that week and i had no std
so i ended up not returning back to the
porn industry and just kept running i
went to san bernardino
after that and i stayed out there for
maybe three years
and i just stayed there and laid low
no one knew me started my life over and
from there you know
i became who i am now so i don't no
longer
do it so much but if i have to push come
to sheriff
i do you know in home calls
i have my selective customers that i
deal with
and what uh what kind of guys you have
as
clients mainly white guys
mexicans i don't deal with blacks
because i'm terrified my pimple is black
so i'm scared i'm somehow i'm gonna fall
back in that line
and so i deal with you know out of race
and i still do the demonic things where
i whip the guys kick them in their boss
pinch their nipples
all the like freaky crazy things that
you know a lot of clients that like that
stuff oh yeah
they love it and they're like a bigger
girl like yourself oh yes
they love it the bigger the better
[Laughter]
it's something about it i have the full
package that they left
nice big boobs nice ass so hey
i just put on the show put on my nice
little outfits that i have
a little leather pleather outfits and
bring my whips and my chains
how is doing this for all these years
affected the way you see men
uh i see it affected me of seeing man
has to be weak
they're not strong anymore they they
don't
care for the women they don't believe in
taking care of their family
or being i guess the man that brings the
bacon home and the wife take care of
the home so i i disgrained men i
think they're weak so you respect men
less probably yes
to the point that now and i date women
oh is that right yes i date women
instead of men
because i feel like i can be hurt by a
woman we're both the same species
a woman can hurt me and she
she makes me feel better makes me feel
more secure
more happy being happy is important
huh being happy is important yeah it's
very important to
you know live your life out here we have
a lot of things going on now
so are drugs are part of the picture for
you no i no longer do drugs
actually i kick them
i'm good for you so i kind of just go
off my bubbly personality that i have
i just keep a positive mind positive
output
and you know
just enter another world for me
into a world of pleasure
pain and fun not paying for me but
paying for
my customers because they love it right
so it kind of
you know heal the pain that i have
inside because i get to beat on someone
to and get paid for it was there stuff
in your childhood that you're
still dealing with you think uh mainly
because i lost my dad at a young age
so you know every girl needs their dad
was there any
like abuse or traumatic events in your
childhood oh yeah my mom used to get her
ass beat
daily all your boyfriends yes and you
did watch that
every day every day and i tell myself i
will never be with a man that will beat
you
because i deserve more than that and i
ended up with
my pants that would beat the [ __ ] out of
me
luckily i didn't lose any teeth
that was a great part about it but black
eyes
you know busted lips
and because your little niche that
you've carved out is a little different
than most of the other girls i've talked
to
uh you're working mostly online and
you're you're a bigger girl and and
you probably attract a different type of
clientele you probably don't have the
traumatic events from working the street
so much that no because right now as
they would say
bbw or bbs or big and sexy
we're at the uh all-time demand right
now you know
every man wants a big woman plus you
know
they hear that our vagina is the
tightest
and never lose its form so what kind of
money do you make
doing that i make anywhere between 1500
or
thousand depending on what they want uh
an hour an hour yeah i make pretty good
money
wow so that's how i'm able to pay for my
car
are you saving money uh no no so how do
you how do you make that kind of money
but not
save it well
i live a life where i want to spend
money i'm not going to die with it
so i don't want to save any
at this moment i'm working on saving
what personality traits do you have that
you think
help you or what are you happiest about
or proudest of in your life
what am i proud of that now i'm
a mom you're confident i'm very
confident
i have no insecurities anymore i don't
think that i'm
a big fat ugly black girl like most big
women would think
in my size and my shape i know that i'm
i'm beautiful i have a lot to offer
and not just with my looks with who i am
as a person you know
i have great different community
communication skills
um i took on a lot of different jobs as
in commercial camera i mean customer
service
parking um the health field so i just
went ahead and succeeded in my career
and kept going i never looked back
and do you i mean do you feel it sounds
like you don't get depressed about your
this this career choice of yours no
because i feel like if i'm going to get
depressed about it then i give
him the power over me so almost like
these men are giving you a little more
self-esteem and power than
yeah than the typical arrangement that
oh yeah i get a lot of
and then sometimes i get sad where
at a point i became a cutter so i did
start cutting on myself because
i didn't no longer wanted to do it
anymore this was recent
yeah recent i have recent cuts on my
body
from it as of these nice beautiful legs
of mine
decided to cut them oh wow you have a
lot of scars
yeah so um that was just to heal my pain
and inside it made me feel better which
is weird
to watch yourself bleed and to harm
yourself
to make you feel good so
if i get depressed this is something i
do
but you know i try to fight it off
because that is an
another addiction to my eyes and you
have children
yes i have two and how old are they 16
and 4.
and did you raise them yeah for the most
part i have raised them
i raised them um believe it or not a lot
of people would think
being in my line of business you
wouldn't be a good mom but i'm an
excellent mom
every day i do lessons with my kids
and you know try to teach them more than
i was taught
do you think they know you do this no
they have no idea
they might know yes they might
most definitely they might know and that
has been the shameful part of it that's
why i always did in close to
closed doors so i wouldn't be out on the
corner right
do you think you're addicted to the the
fast money and this lifestyle
yeah tax-free tax-free too yeah that's a
big part
that's the big part i don't have to give
my money to the government
at all i don't know where it's going to
be spent how is it going to be spent
so of course it's not being spent on our
society because look at it it's horrible
so i love it fast money
fast living i get to get the things i
want
buy the things my kids want so i feel
happy about it
yeah do you do you ever stand back and
look at your life and just think jesus
what
what did i what am i doing oh every
every day that's a part of my life like
come on do i want my kids to fall in
this
type of lifestyle that i'm i'm
portraying and i'm
at home teaching them how to be young
women and young ladies
and their mom out here you know letting
her body be free for the public you have
two daughters
yeah two daughters yeah so i mean what
do you think if one of the day
you saw one of when your daughters
follow you your footsteps
well i i believe not to judge because if
i judge her that will put more
pressure on her and i i'll just let her
be free because
every everyone needs to learn how to
fall one day
if you don't fall you don't become
strong but what are your what do you
girls think you do for a living
well i see mommy go to her nursing job
so that's
all they seem to do so
have you been in love before yeah
this my first my first child's father
this life does this work you know this
doing sex work on the side get
complicate those relationships
he never knew he never knew i was very
great
at hiding it but him being a cheater
made me fall deeper into the life so
and i broke up soon we were together for
six and a half years
i was young when i met him
so me being young
having a young a baby at a young age and
never of course i thought i was in love
i was so in love with this guy like he
was the world to me
he meant everything but
when i found out he had abusive traits
it caused me to turn to be the abuser
so man never abuse women because
sometimes some women
turn out to be the abuser so
i start beating his ass because i cannot
take any blows
any more hits anymore snatching me in a
throat
and pulling my hair forcing me to have
sex and enjoy it i couldn't take it
what's the that's the craziest request
you've had from one of your clients
i had the craziest request
was for me to defecate on them
and rub it over their body i just
couldn't
even though it was praying a pretty good
penny but i just
you said no no i couldn't do it
and play in it i i don't know what's
sexy about that
i don't either crazy world
very crazy all right sandy thank you so
much for sharing your story
likewise thank you good luck out there
you